[Musique]
et maintenant
esi
mon dieu
[Applaudissements]
hamon
[Musique]
kouassi véronique jannot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
bonsoir c'est super il ya plein de bons
gestes ce soir l'émission démarre très
bien
1 alors en plus chaleureux bernard là ya
du lourd là ouais incroyable se
connaissent elles se touchent pas de
cours mais on a déjà travaillé ensemble
mais vous êtes au petit théâtre de paris
au théâtre de paris
personnes de plus ouais ouais alors vous
êtes donc chers véronique jannot au
petit théâtre de paris où vous reprenez
des fameux monologue du vagin à jamais
un moment de l'achat corrigeons donc à
la célèbre pièce de bensen croisille et
ici lawson c'est comme ça qu'on dit et
c'est lawson bien alors si c'est
incroyable non de comédienne qu'on joue
et c'est ces monologues du vagin et
fanny cottençon il se fit d'huez de
christine boisson firmine richard
princess erika claire nebout nicole
calfan lisette malidor vanessa demouy sa
force et ses mollets les femmes se
repassent comme ça la pièce des états
unis aussi c'est une pièce qui tourne
dans le monde entier en fait c'étaient
ses jolies oui il se trouve que c'est
important qu'elles existent comme ça à
travers le monde à ce qu'elles racontent
plein de choses essentielles essentiel à
c'est un texte qui était composée par
eve ensler à partir d'interviews de
femmes de tous âges de toutes conditions
et de tous les pays donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'eux c'est universel au
sujet de la femme autour du autour du
vagin laurent je suis désolé le mot
choque encore trente ans après des
baisses mais bon allons-y et faisant la
promo c'est son côté plaidé
non mais c'est vrai que c'est ça
viens laurent l'origine du monde de
courbet non mais c'est vrai que trente
ans après la révolution sexuelle
on a du mal à parler du vagin tout le
monde est un peu un peu gêné comme ça
même vous bernard pourtant selon
vanguard sérieux pas les noms dans la
vie vous du talent vagin bas ou du
bouddhisme vous dit comment tu dis quoi
on le dit justement arrêté est sous les
noms qu'on emploie pour arriver ça vous
n'êtes là
la gramoune est foutrement services
publics de l'orangé mais si les films et
série club au vagin et heymans et 123
fois mérité de passer page c'est pas
joli non c'est vrai que d'ailleurs on
dit dans la pièce et nicole nicole
croisille et elle dit on peut
précédemment qu'on peut prononcer de
toutes les façons qu'on veut il veut
jamais dire par quelqu'un entre nous
bénisse ces familles n'est pas terrible
non plus ses clés ni ouais ouais ouais
quoi pacifique gynécologue donc oui
c'est un mot qui ne me choque pas du
tout au pénis je trouve ça très clean
parce que ses adhérents du ps
alors
les démences nouveau restant alors
revenir majeur donc monologues du vagin
a créé en 1996 à new york aujourd'hui
jouer simultanément dans 30 pays donc
c'est vraiment un truc assez
exceptionnel 1 la dernière présence sur
scène de notre ami d'aironi que
j'annonce il ya longtemps et a longtemps
c'était dans pleins feux à la meinau
c'était il ya douze ans 191
oui la pièce de kalinka absolument quand
on regarde notre carrière d'ailleurs on
voit que vous avez touché à tout mais
sans vraiment vous investira par la
télévision
je m'investis en fait sur sur le sur le
moment j'ai pas de plan de carrière mais
j'ai pas de plan de vie non plus donc
les rencontres les opportunités qui font
les chantres exactement pas exactement
je m'enthousiasme exactement en votre
vie enfance dorée à la campagne vous
allez chercher du lait chaud à la ferme
votre jugement s'applique à vous
souvenez tous ah oui oui allez nous
allons bel enfant très belle enfance et
puis vous êtes devenue comédienne
complètement par hasard puisque votre
mère envoyez votre photo à un annuaire
de cinéma complètement comme ça et
cécile aubry est tombé sur ces photos
vous n'aviez même pas 15 ans elle est
devenue la partenaire de son fils dans
le jeune fabre avec mehdi le fils de
cécile aubry
mais déjà à l'époque c'est marrant parce
que vous êtes toujours des plans b et
vous avez toujours des plans de secours
déjà les pommes vous disiez si ça marche
pas de façon tombe je suis forte en
langage trop de choses en anglais après
vous ai fait du théâtre vous avez fait
l'école des femmes
1 le rôle d'agnès à genève et puis vous
a été rattrapé par les feuilletons télé
c'est à dire qu'en fait si on regarde
votre carrière
on s'aperçoit qu'à chaque fois que
j'étais rattrapé par la télé il paul et
virginie aurélie et victorien voilà donc
là le théâtre ça s'est arrêté vous y
revenez maintenant mais ça s'est arrêté
après l'expérience de long qui vous
choisit parmi 250 comédienne pour former
avec lui le nouveau couple du cinéma
français vous signez un contrat avec lui
alain delon dia l'épreuve 15 ans voilà
vous saurez la star de demain pour trois
sony on apprend des choses c'est vrai
bien sûr qu'elle émane en trois filles
et voilà à vue d'oeil est d'après lui la
star de demain mais le toubib sap a été
un grand succès le succès qu'il est ce
qu'on fait oui donc en fait on en a fait
cas on en a mais c'est pareil dans la
chanson vous avez fait la chanson avec
voulzy qu'on adore tous d après fini
aussi à chaque fois la télé vous
rattrape par exemple cette pause café ça
marche très bien en fait ça vous devenez
je vais le mazars tout le monde la
connaît mais c'est vrai que voilà la
télé vous a toujours rattraper mais les
août carrière vous avez abandonné assez
rapidement et l'impermanence c'est pas
parce que vous avez peur de dépendre
d'une seule activité non c'est sûr que
c'est assez déstabilisant vous prédire
un petit peu flippant fait de dépendre
effectivement du ca l'activité est mieux
quand on a plusieurs cordes à son avis
une façon de vous protéger en fait c'est
pas conscient mais il ya sûrement
quelque chose que je pense moi j'ai ce
pari avec les mecs vous avez perdu des
portes en mai dernier
mais c'est vrai veronica peur de
dépendre d'un seul homme c'est vrai vous
dit j'ai envie de poser ma tête sur une
épaule mais j'ai peur aussi que les
pôles se retire brusquement c'est vrai
mais oui j'appose mais j'ai un petit peu
en apesanteur voilà si je peux toujours
peur que l'homme s'en aillent et qu'ils
vous laissent tout seul dont vous posez
jamais vraiment la tête
non parce que mais parce que peut-être
les projets déposés j'ai été trahi donc
mais on est toutes pareilles way and on
vous laisse tomber la les autres
bon non non non non il n'ya qu'une fois
vous avez posé votre tête sur une épaule
malheureusement c'était celle de didier
pironi ça s'est mal terminée c'est
peut-être ça aussi qui vous a un petit
peu guéri je dirais des aventures homme
sait pas c'est pas ça parce que c'est
pas un abandon c'est la vie qui a décidé
que mon savoir que ce qui était bonheur
devait se transformer en malheur mais
donc c'est pas ça qui mais j'aime pas
trop parler de de tout ça parce que
c'est des cd des moments des moments
douloureux mais c'est aussi des moments
où je dis on pleure toujours sur ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a aimé on pleure
forcément montrer plus fort parce que
quand on a vécu très fort quelque chose
et c'est vrai que ça aurait duré plus
longtemps serait sûrement été formidable
et puis peut-être que ça n'aurait pas
été formidable si ça va durer plus
longtemps
on ne peut pas qu'on voit est ce que
c'est cette peur finalement de vous
poser je dirais une qui fait que vous
n'ayez jamais eu d'enfant je dirais que
c'est la vie qui en a décidé comme ça
ouais ouais moi quelqu'un davantage que
c'est resté un enfant parce que le temps
commence à se voir
il suffit de vous regarder tant qu'on
n'a pas d'enfant on est un enfant et
vous êtes une femme ans je crois que
c'est une femme enfant parce
qu'effectivement je n'ai jamais eu la
responsabilité d'avoir d'avoir un enfant
c'est une réelle responsabilité de
mettre au monde un enfant surtout
surtout aujourd'hui je trouve
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que je devrais
faire un enfant je suis pas sûr que je
ferai le choix d'en faire un vous êtes
pressé très juvénile trop alors votre
équilibre vous l'avez trouvé cet
extraordinaire dans le bouddhisme et
vous dites ça c'est que vous allez
m'expliquer ça je suis catholique de
conviction bouddhiste ça veut dire quoi
ça ça veut dire que j'ai été élevé dans
la religion catholique j'ai fait ma
confirmation à première communion mais
que j'ai découvert
je dirais le bouddhisme en tout cas la
philosophie vous dira plus tard parce
que pour moi c'est une fille vous êtes
boulistes aussi parce qu'un homme l
avant-midi en voilà c'est vrai on allait
parler avec natacha de bout en bout de
mon association bel et bien sûr bien sûr
et mais le foot de bouddhisme c'est une
philosophie ni avant et le dalaï lama
dit lui même pratiquer le bouddhisme en
plus
n'allez pas renier votre religion bourse
à dire c'est une leçon de tolérance
lamanda je vous ai fait l'objet de lois
de la tête vous au moins parce que
dernier parce que c'est un engagement
religieuse
c'est quoi le principe de base du
bouddhisme aba'a par les tongs c'est
quoi leur on peut vraiment faire quelque
chose d'extrêmement constructif et
d'autant plus constructif que c'est
d'abord pour les autres parce que c'est
un choix de vie un choix de vrai chemin
de vie qui croyez un ami j'ai vraiment
une chose qu bouddhiste
[Applaudissements]
on revient quand tu veux je regardais
femmes du prochain
bon nombre à quelqu'un vous dit ça c'est
au contraire c'est le côté mais ça va
alors oui c'est compliqué c'est très bon
pour le temps là dans le coeur alors
c'est vrai que non c'est vrai que c'est
elle ya des princes sur la seule façon
d'apporter la paix au monde et
d'apprendre soi-même à vivre en paix
bien sûr voilà c'est tout tennis john
lennon lui chantant salles notamment de
la peur dans la rue est désormais tous
les pays du monde on compte désarme pas
l'homme de toute façon toutes les
guerres continuer et surtout surtout
comme disait le poète et mon où vivent
vivons donc heureusement champ arrière
ce qui nous haïssent aimons nous les uns
les autres dans des boîtes échangistes
ce extradé alors la bomba est pourquoi
il serait bon il serait pas finalement
qu'est ce que c'est vous avez commencé
par dire que c'est la tolérance et des
maisons hélas hélas hélas hélas vous
êtes en train de dire que ce n'est pas
possible de semer les uns les autres
dans une maison où ils s'échangent tous
bords
j'ai pas dit que sur l'échangisme dans
la même phrase ya des bouddhistes
échanger sur leur nom sûrement il y en a
même
je vous dérange plus qu'ailleurs
[Musique]
alors est ce qu'on a dit qu'elle était
né à annecy
oui je crois que monde s'en branle les
langes on peut dire aussi ses quatre
jeux qu'on peut dire aussi c'est que
véronique a été élevé à seynod n'est ce
pas bien alors maintenant on va
continuer on va faire une petite
interview alerte bleue l'air tendu leurs
taureaux sur le grand classique de cette
émission est ce que vous préférez
draguer ou faire braquer c'est pas
demain ça ira embrasser vous faire
embrasser les deux mon capitaine
carey s'est ouverte alors un petit
quel est le lieu idéal pour faire
l'amour ça dépend des jours le monde il
ya pas un lieu idéal c'est répondu ça
dépend de l'humeur ça dépend de ce qu'on
vit de commander à ce moment là ya pas
deux alors est-ce que vous avez besoin
de faire l'amour pour aimer ou des mets
pour faire l'amour j'ai besoin d'aidé
pour toi mon amour qu'elle monte
vous commencez pas par faire l'amour
après vous aimez non non non préférez un
mec qui bosse bien mecha fidèles ou un
mec qui baisent mal mais les fidèles
immédiat et est un fidèle à parce que
j'arrive à le cultiver mettra filière
sur une belle affaire que tout est sur
une mauvaise
[Applaudissements]
j'aime tout slogan des voix de changer
un truc l'excès des hommes qui
brandissent l'étendard de la fidélité et
qui en fait qui vous ennuie sobriété qui
sont fidèles
vous préférez le market in amusé voilà
messieurs de la marne on est intitulé
pas non mais on devrait voir un mec qui
est qui gilles bonne humeur quand il
rentre c'est ce que vous dites voilà
[Rires]
c'est déjà bien ou préférez vous
préféreriez qui vous quitte pour un
homme pour une femme
[Rires]
moi je suis pas un homme super g dont
voici ma femme me quitter pour une femme
je serai moins jaloux pour un homme je
serais ravi surtout parce que six mois
est-ce que ça prouverait que j'ai des
doutes et des femmes quand même pas des
livres vous préférez qui couche avec une
autre en pensant à vous avec vous en
pensant une autre avec notre préféré ça
à la lumière voulait qu'on allait
s'aligner
où est indexé baissé serge préféré c'est
un jeu ce que tu peux baisser un peu la
donne
c'était en tout cas vous parce qu'on a
des je suis blanche est très présente et
la non à une soirée exceptionnelle le 8
mars à l'occasion du v day donc de
nombreuses personnalités seront théâtre
de paris alors le le jour du vc le jour
du vagin c'est ça non je crois qu'il y
avait un jour du vagin mois mais un jour
qui est fait pour pour pour lutter
contre toutes ces femmes qui ne sont pas
aimés comme et comme les valentins c'est
pour pour dans les fonds sont reversés
justement à des associations qui
s'occupent de femmes battues mal traitée
à travers le monde et c'est une c'est
une association c'est un mouvement qui a
été initiée par even claire justement
qui vocation l'auteur des monologues du
vagin qui se bat depuis cinq ans à
travers le monde pour justement aider à
la condition féminine et se battre pour
elle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
on va vous laisser filer un je suis
désolé mais il faut que l'ags tu vas
tandem série mais à bientôt vernis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la saga de l'été sur france 2
scénario danemark à toi tu as été le roi
maudit et se découvre je n'ai rien vu
encore le tournage a lieu en pleine
épidémie de chikungunya
ça a été terrible et psychose totale à
psychose totale roulante et beaucoup
beaucoup par parler les nouvelles de
métropole sur un parce que là-bas en
fait ça se vivait très différemment de
ce qu'on pouvait dire ici c'était il y
avait et c'est vrai il y avait jamais à
risque y avait un danger mais on pouvait
se protéger en étant vigilant c'est ce
qu'on a tous fait c'était s'était
approché de nous faire piquer quand même
de temps en temps oui vous avez été
piqué par est un vrai comme les 5 à 12
jours d'incubation on comptait les jours
parce qu'on n'avait pas c'était une
lettre au billard sur les routes de vol
il ya là qu'on voulu partir il ya eu
c'est vrai un moment une
psychose un petit peu sur sur le
tournage mais il ya eu un grand élan de
solidarité
vraiment tous décidé de rester parce
qu'il y avait quand même faut pas
l'oublier avec toute une équipe
réunionnaise avait quand même 60 % sont
10% de le réunionnais qui se
retrouvaient planté là sinon si on
partait je travaille pas et en plus
c'est vrai que pour ligne c'était
important aussi qu'on reste parce que ça
a été c'est catastrophique pour
économiquement
moi je devais jouer là-bas les
assurances n'ont pas voulu que je parte
à la suite d'une déclaration d'un d'un
homme politique à la télé il est où il
disait il ya eu je sais pas combien de
milliers de gens contaminés et le
journaliste lui disais mais est ce que
est ce qu on a une réponse thérapeutique
et il a dit non il faut qu'on vive avec
le lendemain matin j'avais un coup
téléphone des assurances en me disant
que je si je partais je t'ai pas couvert
sur le film et donc voilà j'ai télé
j'étais très malheureux parce que j'aime
beaucoup aller jouer là bas le public
est génial et tout ça j'étais très
triste de ne pas pouvoir y aller moi je
partais un mais mais j'imagine
j'imagine l'angoissent que ça pouvait
générer vraiment il y avait l'angoissent
mais il y avait vraiment il y avait
aussi beaucoup de bonheur à être là bas
aussi subir s'était pas on est sûr c'est
qu'ils jouent là-bas tu fais un prix au
cas où vous êtes resté très
courageusement très zen aux bouddhistes
c'est pas pour ça que fidèle ça fait
quand même non alors vous avez découvert
le bouddhisme auprès d'une personne
proche qui lutter contre une maladie en
récitant une phrase un mantra est ce que
c'est une amie au ring et kyo n'était
pas seulement ça c'était une pratique
beaucoup plus approfondie du collège
wallon sait c'est le son qui est produit
par la répétition de cette phrase à une
fonction sur le sur le cerveau c'est
vrai mais c'est parce que c'est se
concentrer en fait sur a montré son
attention et ça permet de 2,2
si on part là dedans de faire le vide en
fait et en mairie sont contents de ce
qu'on se pose et l'esprit arrêtent de
travailler de travailler tout le temps
les gens sous vide
non non justement on est plein mais ne
soit pas de l'extérieur voilà alors j'ai
fait un livre qui s'appelle trouver le
chemin chez michel lafon
vous n'êtes pas venu en parler ici non
parce que j'en ai pas vu chez fogiel
choisi défaut gérard bitton et comme des
dates non c'est un problème de bâton
plus donc que j'étais en tournée donc
ces termes il y avait plein de choses
qui prêcha de l'été parce que je les lui
ce bouquin tout ça vachement bien et
quand on aura dit des choses formidables
sur les jeux c'est ben oui mais en tout
cas je sais qu'il a fait beaucoup de
bien beaucoup de gens et comme il est
j'ai fait dans ce sens
alors justement dans ce bouquin vous
racontez vous avez un cancer à l'âge de
22 ans qui nous empêcher de devenir mère
à jamais vous expliquez assez
naturellement d'ailleurs que bon bah
voilà c'était presque un mal pour un
gars je vais bien profiter à toute
épreuve en fait c'est ce qu'il nous
appartient de la deûle à transformer de
la baule passé et moi c'est ce que j'ai
eu je crois vraiment le bonheur de faire
vous avez profité bon sur un plan 10 en
or couple un oui voilà oui mais voilà
oui oui je pense que avoir un enfant
change tout dans une vie un sens de
responsabilité qui est
c'est une basse que je pense qu'on a
commencé à prendre a peur de tout le
monde et aussi aux sénateurs pour eux là
seulement que forcément fait plus
attention à ce qu'on fait alors que moi
je c'est vrai que j'ai je n'ai peur de
rien finalement parce que je n'ai pas
peur pour lui vous avez bien profité on
va pas s'appesantir là dessus ce n'est
pas le style de l'émission si francis et
la vie voilà zut j'ai été déçu voilà oui
j'étais maîtresse de la ville oui voilà
on est désolé d'avoir profité
parce qu'on n'essaie pas à l'époque en
même temps et alors non sérieusement au
delà de ça il ya l'humanitaire au
système s'occupait beaucoup d'enfants
tibétain avec une association qui
s'appelle graines d'avenir pour
préserver la culture de ces enfants qui
ont été obligés souvent de quitter leur
pays même pour rester tibétains ils sont
obligés
de s'expatrier sont obligés de traverser
l'école himalayens pour rejoindre l'inde
ou en fait la diaspora tibétaine est
établi et maintient la culture tibétaine
impacte donc ses enfants pour pouvoir
être éduqués dans leur culture pour
pouvoir continuer à apprendre apprendre
leur langue en fait à être élevés dans
leurs dents dans leur langue maternelle
et dans leur culture sont obligés de
s'exiler en lan
ça s'arrange pas cette affaire parce que
moi je me souviens j'avais 10 ans je
voyais aux actualités au cinéma en noir
et blanc le départ du dalaï lama qui
fuyaient le tibet devant l'avancée des
troupes chinoises étaient et voilà 50
ans et aujourd'hui c'est toujours pas
réglé mais pourquoi est ce que le monde
a mis si longtemps pour regarder ce ce
peuple et pour se rendre compte que en
plus c'est vraiment une culture c'est
au-delà c'est en plus un peuple il ya
aussi une culture ce qui est une
richesse planétaire et dont on n'est pas
conscient c'est une culture
extraordinaire c'est magnifique et ça on
ne le dit pas donc c'est vrai que quand
je pense j'ai créé cette association
c'est vrai que ces humanitaires mais
c'est au delà
j'ai l'impression de faire en même temps
un devoir d'être humains devoir de
citoyen du monde
devoir de mémoire du business avec la
chine et la chine n'aime pas du tout
qu'on lui parle du tibet pas du tout
d'après que ce que j'ai entendu l'un des
plus jeunes prisonniers politiques au
monde
c'est là c'est téléphone ce type est un
c'était excitant c'était un tibétain qui
a été enlevée à l'âge de sept ans et qui
n'ont jamais revu et le panchen lama est
le seul qui puisse se reconnaître en
fait le dalaï lama le prochain dalaï
lama donc c'est dramatique parce qu'ils
ont mis leur punch lama donc ça veut
dire que le prochain dalaï lama en fête
sera reconnu par les chinois 1
donc c'est tout souvent là tout ça est
en train de partir en ce qui est
fascinant c'est comment une puissance
aussi grande a peur d'un pays comme le
tibet pour quelles raisons pour quelles
raisons géopolitiques ils veulent avoir
le tibet dans leur zone d'influencé puis
surtout ce que ça donne il l'a
miss et daisy voilà donc un malinois et
se fait il qu'en c'est chez michel
vovelle avait servi
[Musique]
et
trouver le chemin c'est aussi ces
messieurs laffont mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
après l'interview superstition
attention est portée du verre au théâtre
oui je vais te mau corde dans un théâtre
où sur un plaquage interdit quand ça
m'échappe
on me dit vous ramassez les trèfles à
quatre feuilles quand j'ai le bonheur
d'en trouver oui une patte de lapin chez
vous un sextoy la patte de lapin bunny
jeunes telenet a déjà beaucoup de succès
c'est une patte de lapin
ah oui c'est énorme et en plus on
voulait couper sarpaux celle de la
graisse de canard
mais je me souviens quand j'étais petit
j'avais mis une patte de lapin dans 25
et en fait les ouvert quinze jours à
passer vous clasico ça se voit bien
maintenant que je rage et la page
c'est une petite s ur les échelles vos
wii aurait ainsi le seul camp
[Applaudissements]
une échelle moi c'est clair les hommes
sont faites plus peureux du bois les
pattes du genre pour conjurer le mauvais
sort ouais j'ai toujours une fois je
croise les doigts
ouais tu fais tout quoi quand et très
atteint 8 quelqu'un que tu viennes
quelques noms en 13 j'adore à 13 thèmes
bien j'adore c'est un bon chiffre d'août
les cheveux noirs sapeurs des chats
noirs fois non j'ai pas peur de chagrin
parce qu'on en a tué beaucoup c'est
comme les chouettes effraies qui sont
les oiseaux magnifique conte épinglait
sur les granges faut protéger les
chouettes effraies pour mettre des
nichoirs
voilà je le dis à tout le monde ce sera
mon combat aux mains des nichoirs et
c'est ça que tu vas faire maintenant ben
je me verrais me reconvertir dans la
défense des chouettes effraies on verra
moins celui d'amiens pour les chouettes
quand il a raté j'aurai des trucs à
raconter quand le pain dans le mauvais
sens vous le mettez de l'autre côté non
ah oui à la voilà un qu'on a un budget
du sel comme ça toi quand il tombe oui
oui vous savez pourquoi de sa porte
malheur non parce que le sel était une
denrée très rare et que s'ils ont
renversé du sel comme ça coûtait cher il
y avait un impôt sur le sel alors les
gens ils se disputaient alors maintenant
le sel on le doit pas le passé de ce si
jamais il tombe c'est une superstition
qui vient comme ça du moyen âge voilà il
faut le poser et on le passe c'est un
simple conte 1
mais il ya plein de gens qui croient que
vous savez vous qu en chine présent non
mais pourquoi leone ont fait comme ça
ouais parce que les tipis frappé leur
machin pour que le vin ce mélange où la
bière ce match comme ça il était sûr que
l'autre et la famille de poison travail
on se serre la main pour montrer qu'à
pas de larmes c'était exactement tout
départ a pu à l'intérieur toi non mais
ça c'est parce que je suis pas content
je pense et a pas de fuite
quinze jeunes ont trouvé le chemin
c'est michel laporte 1 messieurs
[Musique]